what I want to do in this video is get a
little bit of practice trying to
approximate the area under curves and
also get a little bit more familiarity
with Sigma notation in this context so
what we have here we have the graph of f
of X is equal to 1 plus 0.1 x squared
that's this curve right over here and
then we have these rectangles that are
trying to approximate the area under the
curve the area under the function f
between x equals 0 and x equals 8 and
the way that this diagram or the way
that we're attempting to do it is by
splitting it into four rectangles and so
we could call this rectangle 1 this is
rectangle 2 rectangle 3 and rectangle 4
and each of their heights let's see
they're the interval it looks like they
each have a width of 2 so they are
equally spaced so we go from 0 to 8 and
we've split it into 4 sections so each
has a width of 2 so they're each going
to be too wide so that's two that's two
that's two that's two and their height
seems to be based on theirs height seems
to be based on the midpoint so between
the start between the left side and the
right side of the rectangle you take the
value of the function at at the middle
value right over here so for example
this height right over here looks like f
of 1 this height right over here looks
like f of 3 this height of this
rectangle is f of 5 this height right
over here is f of 7 so given the way
that this has been constructed and we
want to take the sum of the areas of
these rectangles as an approximation
under as the area of this curve
how would we write that as Sigma
notation and I'm going to start it and
then I encourage you to pause the video
and try to finish it so the the some of
these the some of these rectangles we
could say it's the sum of so we'll have
N equals 1 to 4 because we have for
rectangular and I encourage you to and I
encourage you to to finish this up once
actually just write it in terms of the
function use function notation you don't
have to write it out as 1 plus 0.01
something squared so I'm assuming you've
had a go at it so for each of these so
for the first so for the first rectangle
over here we're going to multiply two
times the height so the height right
over here is one and this is the first
rectangle so you might be tempted to say
times f of n but then that breaks down
as we go into the second rectangle the
second rectangle the two still applies
this to is the width of the rectangle
but now we want to multiply it times F
of three not F of two so this F of n
isn't going to this F of n isn't going
to isn't going to pass muster and so
let's see let's see how we want to think
about it so when n is so when n is one
two three four we're going to take f of
so F of n or exactly I should say F of n
we're going to take F of something so
here this first one we're going to take
F of one then here for the second
rectangle we're taking F of three F of 3
for the height for the third rectangle
we're taking F of five F of five and
then so for the fourth rectangle we're
taking F of seven F of seven so what's
the relationship over here let's see it
looks like if you multiply by 2 and
subtract one so 2 times 1 minus 1 is 1/2
times 2 minus 1 is 3 2 times 3 minus 5 2
times 3 minus 1 is 5 2 times 4 minus 1
is 7 so this is 2 n minus 1 so the area
of each of these rectangles the base is
2 and the height is f of 2 n minus F of
2 n minus 1 and so that's that hopefully
makes a little bit clearer kind of
mapping between the Sigma notation and
and what we're actually trying to do and
now it's just just for fun let's
actually try to evaluate this thing what
is this thing going to evaluate to well
this is going to evaluate to 2 times F
of when n is equal to 1 this is 1 F of 1
plus 2
aimes when n is 2 is going to be F of 2
times 2 minus 1 is 3 F of 3
but when n is 3 this is going to be 2
times F of 5 when n is 4 this is going
to be 2 times 2 times F of 7 4 times 2
minus 1 is 7 F of 7 and so that is going
to be we're going to have to evaluate a
bunch of these things over here so let
me actually let me clear this out so I
have a little bit more real estate
feeling this might get a little bit
messy now so this is going to be
actually we could factor out a 2 so this
is going to be equal to 2 times F of 1
is 1 plus 0.1 times 1 squared so it's 1
plus 0.1 so it's one point let me color
code it a little bit just so we could
keep track of things so this right over
here is 1 point 1 so z1 plus 0.1 is 1
point 1 this right over here F of 3 so
this one plus point 1 times 3 squared 9
so 1 plus 0.9 so 1 plus so it's 1 point
9 and then let's see this one right over
here F of 5 that's going to be 1 plus C
5 squared is 25 times 0.1 is 2 point 5
so 1 plus 2 point 5 is going to be 3
point 5 and then finally F 1 finally F
of 7 F of 7 is going to be 1 plus point
1 times 7 squared so this is 49 times
0.1 49 times point one is four point
nine plus one so plus five point nine
plus five point nine and so what is this
going to be equal to so let's see one
point one plus one point nine these two
are going to sum up to be equal to three
and then these two are going to sum up
to be let's see if we take if we add the
5 we get to eight point five and then we
add the point 9 we get to nine point
four so plus nine point four did I do
that right three plus five is
85.5 plus 0.9 is 1.4 yep and so this is
going to be so once again we have the
two times at all so this is going to be
equal to two times twelve point four
which is equal to twenty four point
eight which is our approximation once
again this is just an approximation
using these rectangles of the area under
the curve between x equals zero and x
equals eight